hello oh this is with hello everybody
nice to meet you my name is Charlie and
I'm a youtuber I've been making YouTube
videos for over a year and I've gained
the audience of over 70,000 people all
by myself just using the internet and a
computer which to me is just when you
think about it in terms of that it's
just absolutely insane and I still can't
comprehend it properly it's already made
a lot of sense to me that so many people
sit in front of their computers and
watch one little boy in the UK sit in
front of his computer and talk to it
it's just surreal but at the same time
it's so exciting and I'm so happy to be
a part of it I'm in the YouTube
Partnership Program which basically
means that I can earn ad revenue of my
videos and I can treat YouTube as a day
job a very cool day job I mean a lot of
my friends have jobs doing you know
waiting and all that kind of stuff but I
I have a job on the Internet which I've
built up for myself which is also very
exciting and very awesome and that's
what I do that's what I am I'm 17 years
old and apparently I'm famous on the
Internet
which is nice I'm from a place called
bath which sounds like a stupid name for
a town but seriously my town is good
bath and that's where I live and it's an
absolutely beautiful city I'm like
completely spoiled by the fact that I
live here because I all walk past
beautiful Georgian architecture and I
won't look at it twice because I've seen
it 100 times before and that's well
that's what you get when you live in a
city like bar I do a lot of acting I'm
in a theater group called the young
person's theatre which is in Bath
obviously because that's where I live I
have quite long hair and I like having
long hair because it looks cool but when
I'm in a plays obviously my director
doesn't like you know my friend Trevor
in my face because he can't see me act
so what I usually do when I'm rehearsing
for plays as I have a beanie which I
wear like this and it like pulls back my
fringe it's basically like wearing a
hairband but slightly cooler I guess
maybe I don't know and all this half of
Marks and Spencers I don't know if
that's cool or not but it's definitely
cooler than me wearing a hairband or
hair clips or something that I don't
think I'd be able to pull that off very
well don't ask me to wear a hairband
please
oh no an email that's nice I'm
completely obsessed with computer games
I love them I love Nintendo I love Mario
and Zelda
I love Metroid I love them all it's I
can't get enough Nintendo as well as
loving Nintendo I also love Apple I have
a standard white MacBook 2.4 gave her
processor and heard a 60-bike Giga but
the hard drive something I've only
bought it recently but it is the best
thing that I have ever purchased even
even better than my wii i think because
my old laptop took about 10 minutes to
turn on it was this rubbish Toshiba
laptop that had Windows Vista Home basic
it was just terrible and I used it for
over a year to make youtube videos so
having this is such a luxury because
this is a computer that will actually
work and it's gorgeous it looks so nice
I mean a lot of people don't like Mac's
because the odds they just look pretty
they're not very good I don't care it
looks so beautiful and it makes me a
look at a hell of a lot cooler when I'm
using it I can tell you that much and
that is an important thing about having
a computer looking good with it I think
yeah I can play the guitar I'm
self-taught guitarist
and I'm in a band called chameleon
circuit and we play our genre of music
which is kind of just started this era
of music called rock which is Time Lord
rock which basically songs about Doctor
Who it sounds a little bit weird but
well it is a little bit weird I've
recently written a new song called
friends of the huge I'll play a little
bit for you as the Sun comes up on
another day and the bright light drifts
into I'm usual - I start to sing without
any disarray and a broadcast My Melody
via basic 5 if you want to listen to the
whole of that song then you should
probably buy chameleon circuits album
which should hopefully if we stick to
our plans to be out by Christmas which
is awesome this is the like the first
proper band I've been in and we're
already getting near to releasing an
album it was just it's just insane I'm
having so much fun one of the things I
didn't expect when I started up on
YouTube wants to make so many friends
it's just been insane in the past a
perfect day for me
would be spending it all inside just
being a bored loser
and very lazy this kind of stuff in my
face watch team watching TV just being
as lazy as hell but nowadays a perfect
day for me is waking up at stupid
o'clock getting on a train to London and
meeting up with one of my friends and
just having a ball meeting new people
has finally become something that I love
because before I didn't like it I didn't
like small talk and I was very shy but
now I finally have a chance using what I
have to make a bit of friends which is
very nice if you are a friend of mine
and you're watching this I'll just let
you know I love you very much thank you
for being my friends hello I have so
many people watching me and so many
people subscribing to me and I'm
extremely thankful for it
but I just I didn't feel like I just
talk in my videos anymore I always have
to have some sort of points to it and I
was getting annoyed by that and I just
want to just I just wanted to introduce
myself again introduce myself to
everybody who's new to watching me and
introduce with myself to everybody who
already knows me and I just wanted to
say hi I guess this is who I am my name
is Charlie welcome to my channel I hope
you have fun goodbye